[موسيقى]
بتقيس انه امر صعب للغايه اريد فقط ان
اكون هنا من اجلهم بقدر ما استطيع اريد
اخبار الجميع كيف هو الوضع الناس لا
يعرفون يقال لهم انهم يقتلون بطريقه
انسانيه ليست هناك طريقه انسانيه ويمكنك
سماعهم يمكنك سماع صرخهم وهذه الحيوانات
ذكيه لدرجه انهم محطمون يمكنك رؤيه ذلك في
وجوههم انتظري حتى ترين وجوههم انهم
مكسورون عندما يصلون الى هنا وهم يعرفون
وهذا صعب حقا
[موسيقى]
لدينا من الحلول البسيطه للكثير من
المشكلات التي تواجه الكوكب كتدهور التنوع
البيولوجي والحياه البريه وتدمير الغابات
والفيضانات وتقلبات المناخ التي تحدث
يمكننا انهاء كل ذلك بالتحول الى ان نكون
نباتيين ان الامر يتجاوزني لناحيه اقناع
الحكومه ان تستثمر بمستقبل نباتي
يصارعون من اجل مستقبل النبتي وبالفعل
الهم العديد من الشخصيات المعروفه او
سلاسل المطاعم الشهيره التي لم يخيل لك ان
تستغني عن وجباتها المذقله باللحوم الى
اتباع نظام النباتي
فجهوده هؤلاء لم تذهب سدا وقد يكون
المفتاح ليس في قضيه احتجاجهم وانما في
العثور على طرق احتجاج تصل الى قناعات
الناس وتساعد العالم في التقليل من الاثار
البيئيه التي يتسبب فيها استهلاك اللحوم
كما يؤمنون وكما تقول الدراسات العلميه